we're excited we're very very happy we
had our paper accepted about ten days
ago a paper that we've worked on for a
couple of years and the reason we're
happy is because we've done a fantastic
piece of work and it's been accepted by
Physical Review Letters which is one of
the top journals in the field now you
have to appreciate that this took me a
while this morning Brady so I need you
to be impressed what I've done here is
I've just got a bowl of water and
floating there on the surface is a paper
loop this is a preprint version of it
emergent surface tension in vibrated
non-cohesive granular matter well it's
impressive because you know that a steel
paper clip should be denser than water
and so it should sink but it doesn't
sink and the reason it doesn't think is
because it's sitting on the surface
tension of the water normally it's
associated with molecules such as water
and two water molecules suppose these
are water molecules are attracted to
each other by long-range forces the
water molecules which are this sort of
shape they bond together in little
triangles electrostatically so they're
so small that the electrostatic bonding
between the molecules is quite strong so
what we've done is something completely
different we've taken a box full of
grains of bronze so this not to scale is
a grain of bronze our grains of bronze
150 microns in diameter and we put them
in a box 20 centimetres square let's get
to the point let me show you the
experiment that we actually did I'm
gonna have to turn on the amps that
means it's gonna get a little bit noisy
and then we're going to shake some sound
then we put it in the cell and shake it
up and down this way at a frequency of
60 Hertz and so these are all start
jiggling about all over the place and
you would imagine if you're shaking
these about by jiggling them up and down
they would become randomized and they do
to some but under some circumstances all
of them want to go to one side and you
get a dense phase over here and there's
just a few particles over there this is
our experiment okay so we flip it on and
we're expecting that it's going to face
separate into a dense and a dilute phase
there it goes
these two particles when they're moving
together bashed together and come out
with a lesser speed so if they hit each
other smack on at ten meters a second
BAM they come out with a fraction of
that speed well energy is conserved but
the kinetic energy of the coming in and
going out is reduced because some of
this goes into heating up the particles
and some of it goes into sound so there
is energy loss in the collision and
about 30% of the velocity is lost in
these collisions if they're smack on if
they're gentle ones from the side it's
not so damaging so what happens is if
these come together you get a little
cluster forming and they bash together
so many times that they almost come to a
standstill and when they made a little
cluster another one comes in and bashes
it and it makes a little cluster because
of the elasticity the energy loss in
these collisions there's a likelihood
that they will cluster together and form
little clusters what we're seeing here
is that it's not separating
instantaneously but it's undergoing some
separation through a pattern which we
call spin Odle decomposition which just
the scientific term for the way that
these things separate first of all we
did the experiment this is a picture
after 0.3 seconds that's a third of a
second after the thing has been turned
on it starts off uniform but after 0.3
seconds in this frame you can see little
patches of bronze color
that's the bronze particles and the
darker bits are where few bronze
particles are and it's starting to want
to cluster together into these little
heaps and evolve into something which
you now look at and say all there's a
breach of the continuous path I could
wander around here but what's
interesting we've got a really nice one
here actually what's interesting is that
we've got this little circular droplet
here and the very fact that that
circular tells me that there's a surface
tension at play here but remember what
this is this is just sand shaking up and
down in a box
there's no intermolecular forces holding
things together
this is just me shaking marbles in a box
but it's acting like it's got a surface
tension how bizarre nobody knew that
there will be surface tension in this if
you put water in there's going to be
surface tension of the grains because
the water will make little bridges and
pull them together but before when you
start off with dry grains of bronze
which are nice and shiny with no water
there it wasn't obvious at all that they
were going to stick together if I put a
big bale of hay in the middle of a field
and a hundred cows all came because they
wanted to have it and they all kind of
gathered around it I haven't created
surface tension within cows how do I
show these because there's a big round
blob doesn't mean there has to be
serviced tension it's ironic that you
choose that example because you have
that's exactly what you've done when you
have a system where an animal for
example comes in I'm going to say
normally it comes in at right angles to
all of the other animals then it might
slow down it'll slow down more than if
it comes in tangentially to all of the
other animals because then it can keep
going it's a glancing blow if you think
about billiard balls moving around on
the table if I've got a pack of them and
one comes in and hits the pack square
it's going to stop there and loses all
of its energy but if one takes a
glancing blow it just bounces off and it
keeps most of its energy and it's that
loss of energy at the interface which is
what creates the surface tension by the
very definition we're stretching the
interface just a little bit we've done
ahead and we've measured this surface
tension I've got a beautiful graph where
we can actually see the difference
between the forces pulled this way and
the forces pulled this way just like the
paperclip we've got a weight and then
we've got some tension like a trampoline
skin supporting that weight or we can
see that in our graph this beautiful
circular form and the dark blue region
there is showing you where the surface
tension actually is and we're the first
people who have actually measured that
in a granular system well the idea that
you take something and shake it is
pervasive I mean you know I get my bag
of muesli every morning and I open the
new packet and there's always Brazil
nuts at the top of raisins and you shake
it up and you think it's going to do it
and people try and shake it up or they
try and shake heat up powders in
medicines to try and make it uniform and
it doesn't work because for some reason
things like to cluster together and in
this case they seem to cluster together
and separate out into different bits so
this is something which is not
understood at all in terms of physics
this is one of the big difficult
problems of the age as it were what
happens when you have a system which is
not in equilibrium it's driven from
equilibrium energy is dissipated in some
way and yet it seems to reach a steady
state which you can't describe using the
normal laws of physics
so in here this is our economical
supercomputer shall we call it and what
we've got here as well as a thumping
great dual-core CPU